hey guys how's it going I'm so excited
because today in my kitchen we're not
baking no and I'm with Miranda what's up
guys I'm so excited I'm so excited
Lena are one of the originals yeah I
feel like I'm the grandma of you too but
those are get really old super old yeah
I could probably be all of your moms for
Charlene and my tails maybe since it's
the holidays and we're getting really
festive
I thought it'd be really fun if we can
make some holiday sweaters oh I think I
love sweaters or t-shirts because I
wasn't sure what you'd be into I like a
sweater I'm into a sweater so I got
these at Target for fancy only had one
red one first I add hashtags I wish if
you guys are not hit us up whew we've
got t-shirts you know if you're feeling
it wild okay
red looks really good on you I know I
love red I had someone my favoritest
color we've also got some of the little
lights down put on your sweater yes I
love it battery-powered we have sparkles
oh of course we do zoom in and look they
got this whole box of ribbons and
something else
you had animals you know it's like dead
ones dead ones too like put on it you
know like my shoes got like a dangling
day actually the fern kid who doesn't
have dead animals nails
I had a bird that's unfortunate but yeah
present this is amazing so she just gets
started think we do yeah I mean should
we have like a little competition yeah
well I'll win but we can do that if you
can do a little pool because people can
vote on you know yes did you make that
up did you create that no okay but I'll
take credit for it okay I don't even
know how to do this juice jam and you
jam it in you stick it in the hole
there's two holes though whoa I think I
can feel it
what do you do for the holidays anything
fun um I try not to talk to anybody
and
I make sure I get everything I want or
else I will spit in my mom's drinks oh
goodness gracious what kind of drinks
does she like she likes tea and water is
disgusting I hate the taste of water you
have to taste the water I don't think it
has a taste really water has two things
think about it have you tried eg water
you're right I've died potty water not
potty but I've definitely at feed you
want to try the sink water yes see
they're different teams you're right I
like smart water because it makes me
feel really large I'm gonna say I'm very
disappointed in you because there's no
batteries in this
I've got batteries don't worry I was how
many it says to double triple double be
right back
take your time I'm taking okay perfect
that's nice Wow look at this one this is
nice scissors I've a nice oh I love a
knife careful its sharp I'm ready for
this this is gonna be the best thing you
ever saw I love the holidays I think
they're annoying I just I wish that all
I had to do was just get presents and
not talk to anybody God isn't even
working just being cool oh
there's no me out it's counting there it
is it's warning yeah it's a little it's
a little squirt if you're not fans do
not don't for me I'm gonna unsubscribe
to all of them
I'm trying to glue these lights on but I
have a feeling it's not gonna work out
so it's gonna work half faints you have
a favorite a lot with a holiday snack um
yes I like macaroni and cheese my sister
does is well I didn't ask what your
sister likes I just want to sell them I
don't know why you just told me that
because I didn't ask about your sister I
don't care about your sister or late I
don't want to have anything in common
with her I do not trust her well my glue
gun is already out of blue so that's a
minus for you on the hangout factor of
being friends yeah I'm pretty upset too
mine's NT already you knew that you had
a huge celebrity like me coming over and
you got the sale gun well to see
Pinkett pretty and it was like oh my
gosh weird I'm gonna love it what do you
want for christmas oh I would like a new
drone I feel like an airplane kind of I
don't believe in airplanes I think it's
a conspiracy theory let's talk about it
why do you think those windows are so
small I think we're just driving I think
the windows are just movies they're just
pictures I don't think you're actually
flying I think I go to the twilight zone
or something and then you end up in a
new place everything that I thought I
knew is not anything that I know see oh
my gosh
you're gonna love what I'm doing I can't
wait to see it I don't wear it every day
this month I don't know if I can talk to
you ever again well I hear that you're
having a party that I'm invited to yes a
New Year's Eve party very excited about
it we made something really really
awesome on Miranda's channel
yeah just made a cake pop with an iPhone
inside of it yeah dreams come true it
was pretty much like a dream that I
didn't even know that I had and I had it
and I didn't even know it I mean I know
it now we just pretty much changed the
face of humanity with that one you know
Wow hot is hot glue jeez I think I
burned off all of my fingerprints you
know what that means the good thing you
have the face recognition phone now I
was gonna say we could commit crimes now
huh do you have a plan with yours are
you just kind of going for you no I'm
just using this is more like an
impressionist type thing you know I'm
just sort of like feeling like real
impress oh and impress it like you're
requesting yourself and impressing
myself with every squirt of this glue
gun mistakes are in the eye of the
beholder so maybe your mistakes or
another person's beauty or maybe you're
just not talented but that's not for me
to decide do you see what I'm doing it
actually looks really good oh wow just
wait wait till I'm done Justine I'm
blowing your mind
mine looks like I'm making a Christmas
freakin cats I don't even know what I'm
making I think this is
but I don't know my states this is that
Texas I don't know I think I'm gonna
change it up maybe I'm gonna do like um
something else like a Christmas tree oh
what's this for
did you ever do Christmas planes when
you were younger I think I was like the
baby Jesus once you weren't Jesus I was
like a baby so are you a boy are you a
girl I'm a girl but I was still baby
Jesus but Jesus is a point or is it 2017
you could be whenever you want you can't
be with everyone but that wasn't 2017
this is like greenstick you know they
don't really work to this oh this sucks
well it's your fault for getting the
knockoff brand you didn't know I mean is
there like a glue gun brand that people
use um the ones that work you burn
yourself again yes is that true you can
burn off your fingerprints and then you
can do a crime and no one will get in
trouble it makes sense because you don't
have a fingerprint right so as long as
you don't leave a blood trail like
they're never gonna find you can't get
this freakin glue to stain your right
this glue sucks
everything's on awesome that's not a
royalty-free so do not put that in just
like put in another team I will
everything is awesome you better put
something else in there and you're gonna
get flagged you know it's worth it for
that my favorite movie was the lego
movie I thought you're gonna say your
favorite movie was called demonetized
no which sounds like a horror movie for
youtubers yeah but I think it might be
like a real-life yeah unfortunately it's
a just Jim and I'm burning I don't think
you should say things like that out loud
I said that once they're not in trouble
Ashley don't yell it at church cuz
that's where I yelled it and they got in
really big trouble
I'm sure depolarized Wow wait I don't
think this is gonna hold up on my body
if I try to put this watch this watch
this
you just gotta like squirt it on and
flop it on top all right I'm gonna put
the glue yes
Nani's agree gosh I think we should
invent a glue gun I think we should
invent a t-shirt company because I am
crushing the game would you sell it we
could but it's in a mystery box so we
need to try that next
I agree I really want you to meet my
friend but she hasn't been around it
really long you I do not have friends
just well that's why she has to been
around for a while but her name is a
Justine she's to be my roommate oh
really
and some things happened so what
happened she didn't want to be your
friend anymore I did and I might have
like injured her do you need me to help
you do you need some no I do not need
your help look at your sweater it's
really the best that I think I've ever
done do you need any other presents or
can I steal me you can have them I
really had high hopes for this I feel
like that's a good life lesson that I
hope no no no that your expectations are
very very low and anything that happens
think about it Thanks
do you need something I blame you I'm
sorry I know it's really hard everything
is awesome not if you're on it oh do you
think you'll wear this year is your
Jersey prettier no because Christmas
will be over on true so I'll probably
wear something even prettier than this
I'm getting pretty close to done then
I'll come along I think I am too cuz I'm
sort of giving up should we try to put
them on I mean maybe that's let's hold
them up and show everybody thing alright
well yep oh oh don't break Wow oh my oh
you know oh gosh marki now okay whoa oh
that's really good
that was my light oh that's like the
whole that's the whole thing
[Music]
there we go fix this I have to turn my
on well mine is the train it's a
kitty cat Christmas tree but she doesn't
discriminate against garbage so I put
the garbage onto because trash can be
piping to - I don't even have a
disruption yours is trash yeah this is
actually trash I feel like this is
something that that cat would definitely
discriminate against maybe my cat this
is a toy for my cat because it's gonna
stream to me there if they go together
should we put them on yes okay this is
amazing they need help
thank you they look good look at I
haven't have glue sticks on mine in case
Oh Michael I need to good if something
falls off but let's grab one of those I
feel like I like the placement of my
present oh that's good that's nice I put
my presents right here I think we look
really nice personally and I think mine
is better
I have to agree so even if you guys want
to vote there'll be a pole somewhere on
this video and feel free to vote go
sweater do you like more mine I'm
definitely voting for yours yeah I'll
tell you I don't think anyone's even
gonna like look at well my cat can play
with your bean they're playing tonight
team on a time I think these are not
pretty great and I'm looking forward to
wearing this for the holidays when
Justine what we didn't do a fashion show
oh okay ready yeah
cue the music
[Music]
all right well thank you guys so much
for watching make sure you go check out
Miranda channel and subscribe we made
something super super fun we may have a
do you want to tell them yeah a cake pop
with an iPhone inside of it the world's
biggest cake pop it was pretty mint a
real warranting foam and we're gonna
start a bake shop together yeah
and clothing line yeah but I'll make all
the clothes I think you will I'll work
on the baking happy holidays guys see
you later
well can't leaving me to wait I live
here
yeah shoot
[Music]